à l'est d'orléans entre la loire et la
sologne
la petite commune de ferrol avec son
église son école sa mairie et au milieu
de ce tableau un crève coeur
son unique commerces fermés depuis dix
ans maintenant
c'était quasiment intenable pour une
commune de près de 1300 habitants d'être
victime d'une vacance commerciales
notamment pour les personnes les plus
les plus fragiles les plus démunis et
et on sait encore aujourd'hui en termes
de mobilité tous les efforts qu'il faut
faire pour se rendre dans les différents
commerces
une carence aujourd'hui réparée férole
possède depuis peu son commerce de
proximité en plein centre-bourg l'état
la région le département la communauté
de communes ont participé à 80% du
financement du lieu et la mairie a
recruté un couple de gérants du cru doté
d'une solide expérience commerciale est
fait avec la cci un business plan et je
suis au dessus dans tous les domaines
que ça soit la restauration le bar où la
supérette la supérette c'est un peu de
mal à fonctionner au début mais là ça
commence à venir le les gens commencent
à prendre l'habitude à venir deux
baguettes s'il vous plaît ça a changé
pas mal de choses depuis le temps qu'on
attendait ça je viens chercher mon pain
systématiquement ça me fait moins loin à
aller et on y vient manger de temps en
temps c'est convivial c'est sympa et
fréquenté par les habitants de la
commune pour ses services de proximité
en plus des artisans des chantiers
voisins à l'heure du déjeuner
l'établissement commence de façon
tangible à remplir ses missions de
redynamisation économique et de
renforcement du lien social